[MUSIC PLAYING]
KARL RYAN: So hello, everybody.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
KARL RYAN: Oh, that's more
like the creative folk I know.
Very good.
So you're very welcome to
the first ever spark session
we have here in Cloud Nine,
our dedicated creativity
and innovation
space, here in EMEA.
So yeah, a round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
KARL RYAN: Great.
What a remarkable
company we work for.
We get to drink beer
and eat food and listen
to some of the greatest artists
in the world, all on an evening
where we can join together
collectively, communally,
and collaboratively.
I love it.
So great.
So just to let you
know, tonight is going
to be a really special event.
I'm really, really
excited about our guest.
He's an artist who's really
been on a remarkable journey.
I'm just going to pull out a
quote for you, actually, just
for a second.
He's been on a
remarkable journey.
And it's just a really
interesting story
he has to tell about creativity,
about the art of being
creative, the fear that
comes with being creative,
the beauty of it,
the truth, all that.
So we're going to go
through all of that.
We're going to hear
some of his story.
We're going to hear him play
some of his music tonight.
We're also going to sing
and write a song together.
Can I get a hell, yeah?
AUDIENCE: Hell, yeah.
KARL RYAN: Hell, yeah.
I hear some song
writers in the room.
All right, that's great.
So we're going to
do that together.
This night only works if
we're all in this together.
This is an experience we share.
This is an experience
where we come out beaming,
going I feel good.
Creativity sparks my brain.
This is a spark session.
So I'm really happy to
have you all here for that.
So before I just introduce-- I
want to share you this quote.
Because this I
think really tells
an amazing story about this
artist, and the kind of artist
we're about to listen
to and speak with.
So some of you may be familiar
with a man called Ed Sheeran,
only one of the
finest songwriters,
and most well-known
in the world.
He said this in a BBC
interview about Gary,
who we're about to hear.
He said "the reason
I use a loop pedal--"
We'll hear all about loop
pedals in a minute or so.
"The reason I use
a loop pedal now
is because I saw a guy called
Gary Dunne use a loop pedal.
I was 14 and I was
just blown away.
I was like this is incredible.
I need to get one
of those pedals.
So I did.
And I made friends with Gary
and he taught me how to use it.
And that was the gig
that started me off
on the whole loop
pedal journey."
That is an amazing thing to
say about the artist you're
about to hear.
He's going to start
us off with a tune.
I want you to give him a
massive, Googly, loving,
creative roar.
Ladies and gentlemen,
please welcome Gary Dunne.
[APPLAUSE]
GARY DUNNE: I've got a little
bit of set up to do here.
KARL RYAN: Shall I keep talking?
GARY DUNNE: No, it's cool.
KARL RYAN: OK.
[LAUGHTER]
GARY DUNNE: How is everyone?
AUDIENCE: Whoo!
GARY DUNNE: First
time in Google.
Good vibes.
Good vibes in Google?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
GARY DUNNE: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: The best.
[LAUGHTER]
GARY DUNNE: Spot the boss.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
GARY DUNNE: Are we
singers, Google?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
GARY DUNNE: Come on, warm it up.
GARY DUNNE: Everybody.
Come on, break it
down, break it down.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
GARY DUNNE: Beautiful.
GARY DUNNE: Keep it rolling.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
GARY DUNNE: Beautiful.
GARY DUNNE: Let's finish
together, a couple of times,
"I know."
Three--
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[AUDIENCE SINGING]
GARY DUNNE: Thank you, Google.
Beautiful.
[APPLAUSE]
KARL RYAN: Thank
you, Gary Dunne.
Thanks for being here.
I am intrigued by the loop
pedal, and all that it brings.
Maybe-- could we
start by you just
talking us through what on
earth you're doing there?
GARY DUNNE: Give
me a second, Karl.
KARL RYAN: Oh sorry,
give you a second.
Take a seat and tell us how
does this mad machine work.
And how does it actually
even feed you creativity,
for that matter?
GARY DUNNE: Eh.
KARL RYAN: I started with
a really hard question.
GARY DUNNE: I'm shifting
gears as well, from playing,
to talking about playing.
KARL RYAN: Sorry.
GARY DUNNE: This thing
is called a live looper.
And the way it works is
that I press a button,
and it records whatever sound--
my mic is making a funny sound,
talking about sound.
It records whatever
sound is plugged into it.
So- oh, there you are, fridge.
So I press the
button, play guitar,
press the button again,
and it loops, which
means that it plays on repeat.
KARL RYAN: You can lay it,
and then layer on top of it--
GARY DUNNE: Yeah.
KARL RYAN: -- and the
singing goes on top?
GARY DUNNE: Yeah.
So then you can press it again.
And so you can put down,
(IMITATES DRUM SOUND)
That loops.
Press it again.
(IMITATES DRUM SOUND)
and build a track.
KARL RYAN: So we know Edge
was impressed with it.
How did you get
into loop stations?
I can't imagine there
was a lot of people
using loop pedals back
when you were starting out.
GARY DUNNE: [INAUDIBLE] Karl?
KARL RYAN: No, I mean
you're as old as I am.
So I guess that's
probably very young.
[LAUGHTER]
GARY DUNNE: I got
into loop stations--
I was doing a gig in Cork with
an American songwriter called
Joseph Arthur.
Has anyone heard
of Joseph Arthur?
KARL RYAN: He's great.
GARY DUNNE: Fucking
legend, legend.
And the venue, the lobby,
which is a beautiful-- I
don't know if it's still there.
It's a beautiful room
over an old pub in Cork.
A little small room about
the size of this many people.
Kind of I don't
know, 30-40 people?
And I was booked by
the venue to play.
And I rocked up,
and I was booked
to open for Joseph Arthur.
At the time, I was doing
the kind of standard Dublin
singer-songwriter thing.
There's a certain sound, and
I was very much in that sound.
Rocked up to do my gig.
And Joseph was-- Joe
as I call him now.
Joe, Joseph Arthur
was sound checking.
And I just went what
is going on here?
He not only had a
live looper, which
is a whole creative
performance tool in itself,
he also-- I get emotional
talking about this.
He had loads of
effects pedals as well.
So my set up is just an
acoustic guitar and a mic
going into that thing.
So I can record
whatever I do to them,
and then make it into
kind of soundscapes.
He had these, going into
all kinds of special filters
and things.
So he was creating these
insane soundscapes.
And it just blew me away.
And the next week I went
straight into Music Maker,
in Dublin, to get
me a loop station.
KARL RYAN: Come get the
finest loop station in--
GARY DUNNE: And Damien Rice
was opening on the same tour.
And I met him in Whelan's a
couple of few weeks after.
And we bought our loop stations.
[LAUGHTER]
GARY DUNNE: (IMITATING
DAMIEN RICE)
Where did you get
your loop station?
KARL RYAN: Where did
you get inspired to do
a thing like that?
Well listen, let's take
it back just a bit.
Because I'm curious
always-- and we're
talking about the sort
of creative process.
And you and I had sort of
chatted a bit over email
before this.
But even just growing
up, I know you're
from Laois, just down the road.
And your family life was
quite artistic, wasn't it?
Like that was a
part of your life.
So this must have
informed the way
you thought about
the world creatively
and artistically as well.
GARY DUNNE: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
GARY DUNNE: Yeah, well my
parents are both artists.
So it wouldn't have been the
conventional small town Ireland
upbringing.
My dad is a novelist and
a playwright and a music
producer.
And my mother is a poet
and a ukulele player.
KARL RYAN: Interesting combo.
GARY DUNNE: So my two kids
have a ukulele playing granny,
which is great [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER]
GARY DUNNE: But
yes, so I grew up
in madness, creative,
chaotic madness.
My dad set up the Laois
Arts Festival, which
was a big deal at the time.
And I grew up, I
suppose, in a world
where creativity was default.
It was just constant.
I have go to my room
and write a book.
I have to go to my
room and write a song.
And that was just culture.
You know, the culture was
just constant creativity.
Gigs-- there were lots of
musos and artists in our life
when I was a kid.
And it was always supported.
So when I started playing
keys, little Bontempi
keyboard, when I was
about five or six.
My first gig-- the
Irish people will know
what I'm talking about here.
My first gig was my
first confession.
[LAUGHTER]
GARY DUNNE: We grow up Catholic
in Ireland, a lot of us
grow up Catholic in Ireland.
And they do this funny thing to
kids, where you have to get up
and confess when you're
six or something.
And all the kids
stand there confused.
Am I-- I stole
$0.10 from whatever.
So my first gig was
playing "Amazing Grace"
on a Bontempi keyboard.
KARL RYAN: In the
confession box?
AUDIENCE: On the stage.
[LAUGHTER]
KARL RYAN: That is the weirdest
confession I've ever heard.
[LAUGHTER]
KARL RYAN: The priest is like,
five Hail Marys for that.
[LAUGHTER]
GARY DUNNE: --confession?
This song.
[LAUGHTER]
KARL RYAN: Check this
out, I wrote this.
I'm really sorry.
[LAUGHTER]
KARL RYAN: That's amazing.
Obviously, you moved on
from that into guitar.
Like you took a
journey, obviously,
where there was actually a
pretty thriving songwriter
scene going up in Dublin.
When then later, when
you actually started
playing more formally,
out in the gigs and stuff.
Tell us maybe just
even for people
to get a sense of that
vibe of like, where was
the sort of the locus for that?
I know that there was
very specific gigs where
people would go.
And kind of the people
who were playing.
And what were you
taking from that?
Even just creatively,
seeing other people working
in that environment as well.
GARY DUNNE: Ireland creates
amazing singer-songwriters.
It's something we
do really well.
And I'm not arrogant enough
to put myself in that box.
But we do.
It's something from--
the Glen Hansard,
Damien Rice, Van Morrison,
you know, I could go on,
Sinead O'Connor, Damien
Dempsey, go on and on and on.
That bardic thing's
in our culture.
So when I moved to Dublin from
Port Laois, when I was 17,
I went straight into the
singer-songwriter scene.
Now for those of
you who don't know,
the Dublin singer-songwriter
is legendary.
It was like the
lobby of Erin Cork.
It was small rooms,
where people knew
they were coming out on a
Monday or Tuesday or Wednesday
to listen.
And that is the magic.
It's the listening.
Because when-- even here, when
I'm talking and you're-- like
we're kind of meeting
somewhere in the middle.
And when an audience does that,
it can make or break the gig.
So these were small little
gigs run by grand people
like Dave Murphy, Ken Burke.
We just went to
boozers and said,
can we have the upstairs
room on a Tuesday night?
Yep.
What's gonna happen?
Well, 50 people are gonna
come and buy a few pints
and listen to music.
And it's going to be cool.
And for me, I suppose, as a
formative performer back then,
it was just incredible
to be sitting
in these rooms listening to
heroes, completely unplugged.
Like the raw, pure,
essential stuff.
No mics, completely unplugged.
So people like Damien Rice were
playing to 10 people there.
And it was just electric.
KARL RYAN: Do you remember
the first one, the first gig
you played in that scenario?
Or do you remember the fear?
Like the fear of actually
getting up and playing
a song in front of people?
GARY DUNNE: Are we
going to go there, Karl?
KARL RYAN: Yeah, I think
we should go there.
GARY DUNNE: Fear, man, fear.
The honest answer is the
first time I went to play,
I didn't play because
I was too scared.
You laugh, it's the truth.
I went to the International
Bar, on Wicklow Street.
And that was the kind
of-- I kind of came
to the tail end of the scene.
So there were kind
of songwriters
who had come through scene from
the previous five to 10 years.
And some of them had
done really well.
People like Mundy
had signed to Sony,
and was off touring
with Neil Young,
was on the Romeo and
Juilet soundtrack.
So there were big names.
It was a buzzy scene.
And I came to that late.
But my heroes were still around.
So I went in, and it's
funny-- Damien Dempsey,
who through other work has
become a good friend of mine.
He was there and I
saw him at the bar.
And I went straight into panic.
I went I can't, I can't get
up and sing if he's here.
And so my first gig,
I didn't play there.
And I had gigged a lot.
I used have-- right
back to Amazing
Grace at my first confession.
I was always performing.
But I was just totally
paralyzed by the presence
of these heroes.
So I didn't play
in my first gig.
And the first one I--
sure it was rubbish.
But it was essential.
That's the word that kind
of fits it best for me.
Essential the core
idea, the core song.
No polished production.
No dressing.
It's like the idea,
the song, the message.
And that had a
huge impact on me.
Huge impact on me.
Because-- and I haven't
thought about this before.
I often kind of
reflected on this.
It had a huge impact
on me in the sense
that, especially with
singer-songwriters,
it's either there or it's not.
Like you kind of say
that in business as well.
It's either there or it's not.
You can bring in as many
consultants, as many re-brands,
as many kind of revisiting the
project, and blah, blah, blah.
If it's not there,
it's not there.
And the same is
true in the world
I know best, which is music.
And if you can throw
a big, sleek session
band behind someone, you can
put them on stage at Wembley.
If there's no song,
there's no song.
[INAUDIBLE]
KARL RYAN: Yeah, I
think also, just even--
it's funny you talk about
the purity of the song.
Isn't there a whole
school approach
with producers, when they
make a record, like the best
thing to do is sit
in the car and listen
to it on a shitty stereo
in the car, on the tape?
Because if the song is there,
you should be able to hear it,
rather than just having all the
hullabaloo around it as well,
you know?
GARY DUNNE: The car
speakers for me now
have become my phone,
the phone speakers.
Because most of
us-- hands up who
listens to music on
their laptop speakers?
[LAUGHTER]
GARY DUNNE: Right?
We're list- even
Mp3s, we're listening
to crap quality music.
We are.
Unless you're going into
Wowza, and lossless thingies.
I'm sure there are
techies here going,
this guy does not know
what he's talking about.
[LAUGHTER]
GARY DUNNE: But
I've really noticed,
like when I go back to my my
parents' house-- listening
to an album in my childhood
home was like a ritual.
I will come back to
your question, Karl.
KARL RYAN: [INAUDIBLE].
GARY DUNNE: Listening to
it, it was like good food.
If was like our culture.
When the album
was bought, it was
like-- say making a
coffee in the morning,
straight on to the vinyl.
I can hear the little click.
I can smell the--
the whole thing
was a multi-sensory experience.
And on it went.
My dad has these big
vintage speakers.
And it was like shut up.
We are listening to
the album, you know?
Compared to-- I won't go
off on a whole tangent
about the disposable
nature of music now.
Because it really has it's--
We're interested in the song
for four days, and
then it's like--
KARL RYAN: What's next?
GARY DUNNE: It was
a bit of everything.
Back then, like an album.
An album doesn't really
mean anything anymore.
KARL RYAN: It's kind
of dead, isn't it?
GARY DUNNE: It's all songs.
Song, YouTube, millions
of views, the next song.
But the idea of an
album as a body of work
has kind of faded away.
KARL RYAN: Well even
talking about that,
like so obviously you moved
from that to go and record
your first album.
Was that the shift over
to London at that point?
Or did you record the album
here in Ireland, your first one?
GARY DUNNE: Before
my first album-- so
I was living in Dublin.
And I recorded my
first EP, which
was done in a bedroom in
the north circular road,
near Phoenix Park.
And one of the
tracks from it was
selected to be on this best
of UK unsigned thing, which
brought me over to the UK.
So the album actually
wasn't till much later.
I moved to London first,
hit the scene there.
Then came back to the west of
Ireland to record the album.
KARL RYAN: And even just to give
a sense of that-- maybe we'll
ask you to maybe play
another song in a second.
But I just wanted to
understand, that transition
from the fear of not being
able to play a song in front
of Damien Dempsey, to go on and
gig in fairly sizable venues
across London, and like
getting your chops,
and getting out there, and
getting the songs up and going.
Like what was that
as an artist like?
You're obviously-- you know
there's all the things that
go with any job.
Which is like, how am I
going to make a living?
How am I going to
actually do my job well?
All of that, like it's a craft
that you're honing you know?
And the creativity is
coursing through you.
But you're trying to channel it.
Tell us a little bit about that
journey, from the transitional,
going right, I'm
going to London now.
And I'm going to do this thing.
That's a big moment, surely.
GARY DUNNE: Yeah, it wasn't
that conscious at the time,
to be honest with you.
It was-- I think a lot
of people's early 20s
are a bit unconscious, in
the sense of doing things
in a considered way.
We just kind of do things.
Well, I did.
I just kind of did things.
So what was it like?
I moved to London when
I was, I think 21.
Literally, I decided on a
Friday, and moved on a Monday.
And arrived in London
backpack, guitar, cliche.
[INAUDIBLE] total
walking bohemian cliche.
I arrived in the big city,
bag on my back, guitar.
And it was electrifying.
You know, it was
a different way,
it was a different-- When you
grow up somewhere like Ireland,
where everybody knows everybody,
or knows what-- you're kind
of one degree of separation.
To move to the city
where essentially no
one, doesn't matter.
No one cares who you are.
No one cares what you do.
And that's a good
thing and a bad thing.
Because you can-- it
really shakes you up
to think about who you are.
Because all your
old cultural norms
and your interconnections
and your reference points
are all gone.
You find yourself in this
mix with the whole world.
So that was kind of
the personal journey.
It was like realizing, OK here,
things that people don't know
what people knew in Ireland.
Things that were important
aren't important.
It's just this
big flow of stuff.
So that was the kind
of personal thing.
And then creatively, making
a living as a musician--
I busked on the
tube for two years.
And that was a
learning experience.
I used to-- you just become
like a musical prostitute.
You're in Piccadilly
Circus, and a gang of guys
will come-- football
fans walking on.
You go "Wonderwall"
would work here.
(SINGING) Today was
going to be the day--
then that's (IMITATING
FOOTBALL FANS) Rawr--
[LAUGHTER]
GARY DUNNE: --and throw
you loads of money.
And it's the same
thing-- You think
about a prostitute,
musical jukebox,
But it was, you
talk about chops.
That was heavy.
I used to play down there on
Leicester Square for Pride,
down in Soho.
So obviously loads of
loads of drag queens, loads
and loads of that whole vibe.
And I just had to play "I Will
Survive" over and over again.
And I didn't even know the song.
I'd just do the first
verse and chorus.
That's enough.
So everybody, was on their buzz.
And I would love these
big colorful London,
millions of people.
And me here, this confused
little Irish dude,
trying to make 100
quid to pay some rent
for a shithole in Kentish town.
Just go (SINGING) first I was
afraid, and they'd all go,
I was petrified.
[LAUGHTER]
GARY DUNNE: So my early time
in London, it was a crock.
KARL RYAN: Yeah,
maybe we'll take
a breather, just for a song.
Because I want to
talk to you a little
bit about your more
recent times in London,
and sort of the community
that you've built over there
and been a part of.
But one of first songs I
actually heard you play
was the "Amerikan Folk Song,"
which I absolutely adore.
And I wonder if you'd
maybe play that for us.
It's also a great example
of the loop stuff as well.
GARY DUNNE: Yeah, sure.
KARL RYAN: Is that cool?
Great.
GARY DUNNE: Need to make
this seamless transition.
KARL RYAN: Yeah.
(HUMMING) (IMITATING DRUMS)
GARY DUNNE: (SINGING)
First I was afraid--
[LAUGHTER]
GARY DUNNE: Where have
I put my pick, Karl?
KARL RYAN: Oh, I put it
in your back pocket, yeah.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
GARY DUNNE: I could go
with this all night.
[CHEERS]
KARL RYAN: Gary Dunne.
[APPLAUSE]
GARY DUNNE: Thank you very much.
Cheers.
KARL RYAN: Let's
transition back to talking,
Gary, if you'd like, seamlessly.
That was absolutely amazing.
And it's always a marvel
to watch you work.
So I did want to ask you
a couple of questions.
And then we will get
into the business
of creating a piece of
art together, I think.
Which is another big part
of what tonight's about.
But I did want to ask you,
before we do that, just-- we
talked a lot about
like-- you sort of said
as you were thinking
about tonight,
about talking about
your creative path.
But also that it all connects
back also to community.
And I know that's a huge part
of who you are and what you do.
So maybe just even
just to give folks
a sense here-- maybe
just the transition
from making your
music, all of that time
that you did that, to the point
where you sort of tapered away.
But that energy has gone into
a sort of a community work
that you do now.
And tell us a bit about the
London Irish scene as well.
And where that's gone.
Because I think that's
a fascinating part
of your creative story.
GARY DUNNE: OK.
There's a few bits to that.
KARL RYAN: Yeah,
of course there is.
Let me just sum up
half of your life.
GARY DUNNE: OK-
[LAUGHTER]
GARY DUNNE: When Karl asked me
to come and talk here tonight,
it was interesting to think
about-- it kind of forced
me to reflect on it,
to try and articulate
what I think about creativity.
And it's not something
I've ever done before.
I've kind of just been
in the flow all the time.
So that's kind of
one part of it.
And then to do
that, I'm thinking
about my own kind of story.
I went back, looked
back over kind of 15,
20 years of doing
creative stuff.
KARL RYAN: It's the
international symbol
for creative stuff.
[LAUGHTER]
GARY DUNNE: Yeah.
And I've had a
"portfolio career."
I've had a mixed bag of stuff.
But the constant threads
through the whole thing,
which were screaming at me when
I looked back over to think,
were creativity and community.
And those two things, for me,
are completely interwoven.
Because people
love making things.
Hands up here who would like
more creativity in your life?
Felt a bit Oprah, didn't it?
Who wants to talk about--
[LAUGHTER]
KARL RYAN: There's
a bit of creativity
for everyone in here.
GARY DUNNE: You know, now
that I've got that license,
I'm getting up on my soap box.
This is what I think
about creativity.
But it's-- and again, I will
come back to what you've asked
me.
But it's an improvised
nature of things.
KARL RYAN: I like where
you're going with this, Gary.
GARY DUNNE:
Creativity, I believe,
based on my own
creative practice,
with absolutely no theoretical
kind of neuroscience stuff,
that creativity is a
fundamental part of humanity.
I think part of why
we're here is to create.
Now you can expand that out
and talk about your life,
and go every moment that passes,
you are creating your life.
Your greatest creative
act is your life.
Are you going to stay
working in Google?
Are you going to move
home to Paris and do this?
Are you going to set up,
are you going leave your job
and open a cafe?
Are you going to buy that top?
Are you going to raise
your kids this way?
We're in constant self-creation.
So anything that
I've been involved in
has been around that energy.
When I was a 12-year-old,
I was a member
of our local tennis club.
That's tennis, Karl.
That's creativity.
KARL RYAN: So creativity--
GARY DUNNE: Tennis.
KARL RYAN: Tennis.
We got that?
We're good.
OK.
GARY DUNNE: And local tennis
club, small town tennis club.
Crap at tennis I was.
But it was where
everyone hung out.
And there was a room, a space
like half the size of this.
And my instinctive thing was
we have got to run gigs here.
And I guess that creativity
is seeing what doesn't exist,
and feeling
compelled to make it.
And that's what I
have always done.
And it only happens
in community.
Now Karl, and whoever else
was involved, and I'm not--
and I don't know who
else is involved,
in making tonight happen,
has or had a vision for what
this thing could be.
And I love that vision.
How I understand that
vision of coming together
to talk communally,
to talk creativity
and spark off each other.
And that's what
I've always done.
And the two are
completely interwoven,
community, creativity.
People come together,
they make things.
People want to make things.
Making better things, making
things better, in communion,
in community.
It's completely
interwoven, you know?
A song doesn't fully exist
until you sing it to people.
If a tree falls, etc.
But I mean, when
I'm at home writing
my tracks in the bedroom blah,
blah, blah, banging out a song.
Oh killer, it's done.
I do not know that song until I
stand up here and sing for you.
Then I go, oh god, it's crap.
KARL RYAN: Or it's
crap that night.
GARY DUNNE: Or it's
That's a whole other
thing, inner connection.
For me, the function
of art, for me,
if we're going to branch out
creativity, culture, art.
The function of art
for me is to connect it
to ourselves and to each other.
If you're going to see
a movie with people,
it's kind of part
about the movie,
but it's more about
art as social object,
and the connection that you
have with the people you
are watching the film,
your experience in this.
The artist made it
had a certain vision,
you're connecting
in that vision.
It's that constant
communion, the communion part
of community.
And that is what I'm about,
creativity and community.
I think you're a bit
like that as well.
KARL RYAN: Yeah, certainly.
Absolutely.
And I think even just when
I think about your story,
even just when you talked
about how you kind of took
a break from gigging,
and that sort of stuff.
But that creative spark,
that communion spark,
that ideal of bringing
people together
in the service of
like an artistic idea,
or a creative idea, I think is
a huge part of the work you've
done with the London Irish
Center and also the St. Patty's
Day thing.
I mean that's a colossal
community of people
that you're connecting.
Just even give people
a sense of kind of what
that work is that you do now.
I think that's really
interesting too.
GARY DUNNE: Yeah, well
I'm director of arts
at the London Irish Center.
And the London Irish Center is
a charity and an old building
in North London.
It was settled in the 1950s
for a huge wave of Irish
that moved here when Ireland
was in deep recession.
Post-World War Britain, WWII
Britain, hundreds of thousands
of Irish moved from
here to the UK.
And this place was set up to
give basically a bed and a job.
So kind of those two things,
it looks after people,
and it kind of
brings them together.
And about six or
seven years ago,
I was living in Camden
Town, which is historically
quite an Irish area.
And I realized one day that all
the homeless guys on the street
were Irish.
And I had moved to London-- I
had left in the Celtic Tiger.
I grew up kind of
European Irish, you know?
I had left-- I'd
moved to London.
I think all of us have moved
into a international mix.
My wife is Swedish.
And I was kind of
in that global mix.
And the whole-- I very much
felt like I'm in London.
And I've kind of left--
not left Ireland behind.
But I'm not there anymore.
And as I said,
one day I realized
there were six or
seven dudes from here
to the Tube station, which
is probably a 15 minute walk,
and I realized that
they were all Irish.
And I said, what
is going on here?
If you're not Irish,
think if you're Spanish,
if you're whatever,
you know Slovakian,
if you go to a
global city, and you
realize that all the
people on the street
are your compatriots.
It was a bit of a kind of what?
So I Googled.
There you go.
And I--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
KARL RYAN: Alta Vista'd.
[LAUGHTER]
GARY DUNNE: I Googled
Irish, homeless, London.
I was genuinely
like, what the f--?
And coincidentally, this place,
London Irish Center came up.
Got involved there
as a volunteer.
And this is where the creativity
and the community interplay.
So I signed up as a
volunteer to begin with,
which basically
means you're going
visiting quite broken,
socially isolated,
lot of mental health issues,
older Irish in London nursing
homes and old flats.
And I ran a kind of soup kitchen
for homeless Irish in London.
And me being me, like week
two I had them blogging.
And kind of singing
songs of their childhood.
I just, to me, that community
aspect, the creativity needs
community and the community
needs the creativity.
That's why when we
come together, we sing.
That's why when we come together
we talk about books we've read.
That's why when we
go to festivals,
we go-- something in us
resonates much more deeply.
That happens for me, anyway.
Nod if you've felt this.
KARL RYAN: Yes.
GARY DUNNE: You
go to a festival,
you go to Glastonbury,
you go to Electric Picnic,
you go, wow, I need
to think about chess.
[LAUGHTER]
GARY DUNNE: Because we're there.
It's a communion.
That's what the art and the
culture and the creativity's
for.
To bring us together.
To connect us to ourselves.
And to connect-- exactly
what we're doing now.
Bunch of people in
a room, connecting
through culture and creativity.
So long story short, I
started doing a project called
"Creatives" with them.
KARL RYAN: You saw a room, and
said I need put a gig in there.
GARY DUNNE: Yeah, it
was a bit of that.
It was more I saw people, and
I wanted their story, actually.
It was more like I can perceive
you as 75-year-old socially
isolated guy from
Derry, or you can--
KARL RYAN: Tell me your story.
GARY DUNNE: Tell me your story.
It was heavy, heavy stuff.
And that evolved into being
cultural officer, and then
director of arts.
And there's this beautiful
cultural regeneration
happening at the London
Irish Center at the moment.
Dermot O'Leary, the
"X Factor" judge,
has come aboard as a patron.
All the big musos like
Martin Hayes, Glenn Hansard,
Sharon Shy, all the big
Irish musicians play there.
We've got kind of
75,000 people plugged
into our social media, which
is big for a specific community
in one city.
And it's cultural regeneration.
It's coming into something that
has a little bit lost its way.
And it's not my doing.
I was part of the spark.
But there's a team of people.
It's a case of alignments,
you know, a bunch of people.
And it's moving at the moment.
And separately to that work,
I'm creative programmer,
of the London St.
Patrick's Festival,
which is a concert that happens
in Trafalgar Square every year.
KARL RYAN: Big gig.
GARY DUNNE: It's
a big gig, yeah.
Then it's parade through
London, 100,000 people.
Then we do events all
across London as well.
We've had you know, Riverdance,
and Lord of the Dance,
We've had once the musical.
Everyone who's
anyone has played it.
And it's amazing.
But it's the same
underpinning principle of--
KARL RYAN: --bringing together.
GARY DUNNE:
Communion, community.
KARL RYAN: Yeah, absolutely.
And for any of you who
do travel to London,
I strongly recommend going
to the London Irish Center.
Gary's being extremely humble.
He has brought a
huge amount of art,
and brought a real focus
on the Irish arts again.
We're in a golden age again
for spoken word, and music.
And a lot of it is
channeled through there.
So [INAUDIBLE] for that.
I really, really, really
respect that a huge amount.
Just one last thing
before we actually
get cracking to make a
song here with these folks.
I just wanted to
ask you one thing.
And it's something that actually
is a topic we talk about Google
a fair bit around,
well-being and mental health.
I know that you've
trained quite deeply
with the mindfulness stuff.
And I know that's something that
you're really passionate about.
I know we said we'd
go face the fear.
And this is something
I think people
are afraid to talk about
sometimes, is mental health.
Tell us about just
that if you can.
I know it's hard to
sum up in a short way.
But that transition to why
is that important to you?
Or like where does
that spring come from?
And what is it doing for your
creativity for that matter?
GARY DUNNE: It's a
big question, Karl.
KARL RYAN: I know, I know.
But I only ask the
big ones, Gary.
That's all I do.
GARY DUNNE: Look the
honest answer here-- there
are a few pieces to this.
Firstly, I don't sign up for
the tortured artist archetype.
You know suffering for my
art, and I'm an artist,
so I can be a prick.
Being an artist is
difficult. So is
being whatever your role
is in Google at times.
So is being a surgeon.
So is being a plumber.
So is being a nurse with
people who are terminally ill.
Being an artist is not magic.
|t's a thing you do.
You make things.
So my point there, is
that the healthier I am,
the more creative I am.
I used to sign up for that
troubled thing, you know?
Kind of treat people like
crap, because I'm an artist.
I'm working on my album.
I'm in a bad space.
Whether it's a
startup or it's you
know, if a new boss starts here
and things start falling apart.
You know, work is
a part of our life.
And it can be difficult. And
you have to navigate that.
And my work is art
and creativity.
So I'm just going to
put it out there, Karl.
Because I said I would.
KARL RYAN: Put it
out there, man.
GARY DUNNE: Mindfulness
a huge part of my life.
And that came from-- I was
recording my second album
about, I I don't
know, a few years ago.
And I started having
panic attacks.
And I was-- there was stuff
going on in my personal life
as well.
But I started having like
full on panic attacks.
And I know I was being
a kind of anxious soul.
You find a lot of creative
people-- sensitivity
helps if you're creative.
It's the whole
empathy thing, being
tuned into where people are at.
And so I've always
been that kind
of slightly nervy,
sensitive creative type.
[ALARM BEEPS]
GARY DUNNE: Wow, what's that?
KARL RYAN: I'd have to take
the bread out of the oven.
[LAUGHTER]
GARY DUNNE: Saved by the bell.
Quick, too many
[INAUDIBLE] people.
[LAUGHTER]
KARL RYAN: fine.
We're fine now.
Sorry.
Sorry for that
interruption, Gary.
GARY DUNNE: Yeah, so
I was doing an album.
And I started having
panic attacks.
And for anyone who's
never had panic attacks,
it's fucking hell.
You think you're going to die.
And I went to my GP.
And she said, medication
or meditation?
A wise old Jewish
woman in North London.
Medication or meditation.
And I said, meditation, please.
And she signed me up for
a mindfulness course.
And I don't want to use words
that are as tired as, "it
changed my life."
But it did.
And the whole self-care,
self-awareness, kindness,
compassion, gratitude,
fundamentals--
And it's a fundamental
thing in my life.
I couldn't, here be
here tonight-- sorry
if this is going to mess
with that recording otherwise
[INAUDIBLE].
I couldn't-- I was shitting
myself before today.
Absolutely crapping
myself with nerves.
Meditated, grand.
AUDIENCE: Whoo-hoo.
GARY DUNNE: Any
meditators in the room?
Any mindfulness heads?
Lovely.
Secular meditation is my trip.
And it's the self-care piece.
You can work, and worry,
and waste your life
away through creating
disaster things in your head.
Or you can learn through
practice how to be present.
KARL RYAN: That's why--
GARY DUNNE: And it's helped me.
It's changed my life.
It's helped me massively.
It has made everything better.
And it's a key-- I
couldn't create--
it's the self-care
piece of committing
your life to creativity.
'Cause creativity is scary.
Because it creates uncertainty.
And uncertainty is scary.
And my whole life is
that, other than my kids
and my wife and other things.
But my working life is all
about creating the unknown,
uncertainty, fear, [INAUDIBLE].
It's why I need that.
KARL RYAN: Well thanks a
million for sharing that, Gary.
It is something that I try to
make part of my life as well.
So in the spirit of uncertainty,
and fear of facing shit
that's difficult,
what do you say
we try and write a song here?
And maybe just to
kick things off, will
you and I just show
what we're going to do?
And then we'll gradually
pull people up, and maybe
write some kind of a song?
Does that sound
like a good plan?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
KARL RYAN: Is everyone
on board with that?
GARY DUNNE: We can try.
KARL RYAN: Yes?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
No.
KARL RYAN: All right.
OK.
So maybe-- what's
the best thing?
Do you want to give me a beat?
And I'll shout something
in a microphone.
And that will be
a starting point.
And then maybe somebody else can
come up and sing a melody line.
And listen, we're all
about facing these fears.
It's not going to be easy to
come up here on a microphone.
But you should face that fear.
Because it's going to be good.
And also, failure is fine.
In fact, failure is just
actually acceptable.
We can also stop the
loop at any time, right?
Go, let's start again, right?
GARY DUNNE: Yeah, we can.
KARL RYAN: Yes we can.
All right.
GARY DUNNE: But this is it.
It's the fear thing.
How many people here
would feel comfortable
standing up and singing a song?
Great.
That's a high-- that's a good
Google culture going on there.
Strong people.
[LAUGHTER]
You ask that in another
place, and it's like, what?
KARL RYAN: They actually leave
at that point. [INAUDIBLE]
he's going to ask me,
it's like school, right?
I'm absolutely with you, Gary.
I think it's that,
it's like you said.
It's one thing having written
a song and putting it out
in the word, or written a poem,
or whatever it is that we do,
our creative selves.
But the act of creating in
the moment, collectively,
that even-- like that's
a whole other level.
Because it's actually--
anything can happen, right?
But that's also the best bit.
Anything can happen, right?
GARY DUNNE: Karl
and me are looking
at each other going, what are
we actually going to make?
[LAUGHTER]
KARL RYAN: Fuck it.
Give me a beat, and
we'll see where we go,
and see what happens.
And then we'll do one
that may be a bit more
structured after this.
How about that?
GARY DUNNE: This is simply
to illustrate the process--
AUDIENCE: Yes, yes.
GARY DUNNE: --of what
we're going to do together.
KARL RYAN: This is where
we get it horribly wrong,
and then we try and
do it horribly right.
GARY DUNNE: So we're doing
nothing-- we're making excuses.
KARL RYAN: Oh yeah--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
GARY DUNNE: We are--
KARL RYAN: --fucking
crush this, dude.
GARY DUNNE: This music is
going to change your life,
motherfuckers.
[LAUGHTER]
It's gonna be the best
song you ever heard.
Except for the next
one, which we all make.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
KARL RYAN: Oh, there you are.
GARY DUNNE: Maybe
that kind of a groove.
KARL RYAN: Yeah.
GARY DUNNE: [INAUDIBLE]
in kind of [INAUDIBLE].
KARL RYAN: Yeah, yeah, OK.
Let's do it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
GARY DUNNE: I'll tell you when.
One, two, three, four.
KARL RYAN: Now, now, now, now.
I'm not saying it's
going to be great.
I'm saying it's going to be now.
[LAUGHTER]
Do we try that again?
GARY DUNNE: I missed that.
KARL RYAN: He missed it.
GARY DUNNE: Two, three, four.
KARL RYAN: Now,
now, now, now, now.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
GARY DUNNE: It's
really good, isn't it?
[LAUGHTER]
KARL RYAN: [INAUDIBLE].
OK, are we going again?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
GARY DUNNE:
[INAUDIBLE] down maybe.
One, two, three, four.
KARL RYAN: (SINGING) I
want to hear your song.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
GARY DUNNE: What's next?
KARL RYAN: Does anybody
want to come up--
GARY DUNNE: I know
we've got a [INAUDIBLE].
KARL RYAN: Anybody want
to give us an oooo?
GARY DUNNE: Me too.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
AUDIENCE: Go now.
Go now.
[APPLAUSE]
KARL RYAN: Everything is
happening right now, people!
It's magic!
Can you feel it?
Would anybody else like
join in, join one more?
Give us another line.
Who's in?
Come on!
You can't be that shy.
We're going to have
to get it started.
GARY DUNNE: Come on.
KARL RYAN: [INAUDIBLE] noise.
He's coming to the mic.
GARY DUNNE: Three, four.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
[MUSIC PLAYING]
GARY DUNNE: Shit's getting dark.
It's getting dark.
[LAUGHTER]
KARL RYAN: Ready?
AUDIENCE: (SINGING WORDLESSLY)
GARY DUNNE: Give
us that one again.
Give us that one
again, over and over.
AUDIENCE: (SINGING WORDLESSLY)
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
KARL RYAN: One more layer?
[INAUDIBLE] let's do--
GARY DUNNE: Let's just
give that piece of music
a huge round of applause.
KARL RYAN: Yeah!
[APPLAUSE]
[INAUDIBLE] everybody joining
in in the spirit of that.
OK.
Let's put a little
structure on it, Gary.
What do you reckon?
GARY DUNNE: Fair
play to everyone
who came up to the mic--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
KARL RYAN: Yes, massive respect.
Give them a big
round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
That's bravery,
that's creativity.
Face that moment.
Nice.
OK.
GARY DUNNE: Do you know what?
How much time have we got?
We got five minutes?
KARL RYAN: Oh, we've
got-- yeah, definitely.
We've got five
minutes, if not more.
GARY DUNNE: When I-- one of the
things I used to do-- I still
do it sometimes.
I went to schools in
London with this setup.
So basically, loop
station-- and you all
know what that is now, live
recording, and a guitar.
And being mental.
And I work with kids in
this kind of setting.
I say, all right, we've half
an hour to write a song.
And they go, what?
And we're going to go
through the process
that we're going to go to.
But just to set the
bar, a bunch of kids
in Hackney, East London,
wrote this in 25 minutes.
No pressure.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
F-R-I-E-N-D-S, (SINGING) All
is good, forget the rest.
F, R, I, the very best.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
KARL RYAN: It's amazing.
GARY DUNNE: It's brilliant.
KARL RYAN: Let's give
a round of applause
for the kids in Hackney.
[APPLAUSE]
So, they set the bar, there.
GARY DUNNE: The
bar is set, dudes.
You gotta meet it.
KARL RYAN: We're
going to have to-- I
want to see some super Google
achievers get up here and write
some songs.
All right.
I reckon if I could
put a framework on it,
it's like let's write a
team song for this space,
or write a song for
the spark sessions.
What do you say?
Does that sound
like a good plan?
Yes, say hell yeah.
Can I get a hell, yeah?
AUDIENCE: Hell yeah!
KARL RYAN: That's
the right attitude.
Correct, again.
Fantastic.
OK, so if we're writing
about spark sessions,
I want you to shout out--
what do you reckon, Gary?
Get them to shout out things
they associate with it?
GARY DUNNE: Yeah, I think every
[INAUDIBLE] this song here.
Song is about spark.
KARL RYAN: Spark.
GARY DUNNE: Throw
words at us, come on.
Spark.
KARL RYAN: Give me words.
Spark of what?
Sparks--
AUDIENCE: Excitement.
KARL RYAN: Excitement, OK.
AUDIENCE: Spark is a lark.
KARL RYAN: Spark is a lark, OK.
We're getting phrases already.
Nice.
GARY DUNNE: That's
verse two, written.
KARL RYAN: Yeah,
verse two, no problem.
Brilliant.
Yeah, excitement.
I'll say ideas.
GARY DUNNE: I'm going
to put creativity.
KARL RYAN: Creativity, yeah.
GARY DUNNE: Making.
KARL RYAN: Making.
King
AUDIENCE: Craziness.
KARL RYAN: Craziness, I heard.
Did I hear explosion?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
KARL RYAN: Nice.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Lightning.
KARL RYAN: Lightning--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
GARY DUNNE: Where's he going?
KARL RYAN: (SINGING)
Oh, whoa, oh whoa.
Fantastic, yeah.
What else do we got?
Any other thoughts?
These are going to form the
lyrics of our amazing song,
or at least the ideas behind it.
Any other thoughts
on what a spark--
What do sparks do?
What are we doing here, tonight?
AUDIENCE: Ignites.
KARL RYAN: Nice, yeah.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Ignite.
KARL RYAN: Ignite, oh
yeah, now you're talking.
All right.
OK, any other thoughts?
GARY DUNNE: I've got it,
come on baby, light my fire.
[LAUGHTER]
KARL RYAN: Come on
baby, light my fire.
Fire, fire, fuego, fuego.
Let's do some
international lyrics.
We're an international place.
Yeah, see, I speak some Spanish.
AUDIENCE: Together.
KARL RYAN: Together,
coming together, OK.
All right.
Any last thoughts?
AUDIENCE: Right now.
KARL RYAN: Right now.
I like that.
GARY DUNNE: (SINGING)
Come together--
KARL RYAN: (SINGING)
--right now, over hmm-- OK.
Fantastic.
So, does anyone
fancy taking a shot?
Or what's the best
next thing, Gary?
Here--
GARY DUNNE: What I
usually do-- so right,
this is about the
song is about sparks.
So what we want here is
some kind of a little--
let's say I'm
talking about verse
and a chorus around spark.
KARL RYAN: OK.
GARY DUNNE:GARY DUNNE: And Karl
has just blagged himself a free
team tune for his event.
[LAUGHTER]
OK, spark.
All right.
So that's what
the song is about.
Next thing.
We have a song.
You're looking at
a rhythm/tempo.
So is it like fast, slow?
You're looking at melody,
some kind of a tune.
And you're looking at words.
So these are the bits.
Any of the musos in the
room are going, yeah I know.
But for people who
don't write songs,
that's what we're looking at.
We'll write this
song about spark.
So let's talk--
KARL RYAN: We'll talk about--
GARY DUNNE: The rhythm.
KARL RYAN: The rhythm.
OK, that's a good start.
That's the beat, the vibe.
GARY DUNNE: (SINGING)
[INAUDIBLE].
KARL RYAN:
Singer-songwriter style?
GARY DUNNE: (SINGING)
Can you hear me?
[LAUGHTER]
Any thoughts on
the vibe for spark?
AUDIENCE: Rhythm.
KARL RYAN: What kind of beat?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: Fast.
Yeah, upbeat.
KARL RYAN: More pumping
beat, is that what I heard?
[BEAT THUMPING]
How do we feel about that?
GARY DUNNE: Well, my rhythm--
KARL RYAN: Where [INAUDIBLE]
somebody give us a beat.
Like sound it out if you can.
Do you have a beat
that you want to hear?
GARY DUNNE: Feel free to talk
about other musical references.
We are a mashup of the
culture we consume.
It's fine.
I'm thinking Pharrell
Williams-type [INAUDIBLE].
KARL RYAN: Oh, yeah?
GARY DUNNE: I don't know
what that means yet.
KARL RYAN: And a
"Happy" hip hop.
GARY DUNNE: "Happy" hip hop.
KARL RYAN: What did you say?
AUDIENCE: Gust of
wind, I'm hearing.
KARL RYAN: Gust of wind?
You want--
GARY DUNNE:
[IMITATES GUST OF WIND]
[LAUGHTER]
Oh, the song by Pharrell, as
opposed to a gust of wind.
We can add a gust
of wind, though.
We can do whatever we want
with this loop station.
That's the beauty of it.
OK, well then I think maybe
just a very nice solid beat
that's kinda got a
hip hop vibe to it.
I think that was
what we could go for.
Does anyone else have
any thoughts on it?
Yes?
Come on.
We're writing it together.
GARY DUNNE: We need your ideas--
KARL RYAN: We need your ideas.
GARY DUNNE: -- in
our consciousness.
KARL RYAN: You saw what
[INAUDIBLE] Gary, what we
wrote already.
[LAUGHTER]
You can get what you write.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Can it change?
Can it start slow,
and then build like--
KARL RYAN: Start slow and build.
Slow and build.
I like what you're saying.
So maybe like a bit of the
singer-songwriter thing,
and then we kick into a beat.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
KARL RYAN: Now you're
talking. "Bohemian Rhapsody,"
like four movements.
Slow down there, boys, OK?
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
GARY DUNNE: (SINGING)
There's a la-- hmm--
Oh, fudge, [INAUDIBLE] OK.
KARL RYAN: You're OK?
GARY DUNNE: We weren't there.
And now we are.
KARL RYAN: Now we are.
That's what we're writing now.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
KARL RYAN: But I think we still
need to establish our beat.
Because we need to know
where we're going with this.
Right, don't we?
OK.
GARY DUNNE: OK, so
for the main track.
KARL RYAN: The track, yeah.
GARY DUNNE: [INAUDIBLE]
straight down.
[BEAT PLAYING]
KARL RYAN: I think so.
GARY DUNNE: People
happy enough with that?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
GARY DUNNE: The intro can be--
KARL RYAN: We're all on board?
GARY DUNNE: The intro can
be a whole other thing.
The intro can be a whole other--
KARL RYAN: Beautiful soundscape.
GARY DUNNE: We
have to figure out,
is the intro gonna
set the color?
Or is the intro going to build
to when the beat comes in?
KARL RYAN: Well let's
put the beat down.
GARY DUNNE: Yeah, let's
get the beat down.
What am I doing?
[BEAT THUMPS]
KARL RYAN: That was amazing,
how did you do that?
[LAUGHTER]
GARY DUNNE: This thing
also has backing tracks.
I don't use them.
(PLAYBACK) This thing
also has backing tracks.
I don't use them.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: There we go.
KARL RYAN: Should we keep that?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
KARL RYAN: I think
we might lose it.
GARY DUNNE: Here we go, undo.
Thankfully, it has
an undo as well.
[BEAT THUMPING]
Are we writing a
happy or a sad song?
AUDIENCE: Happy.
KARL RYAN: Happy, OK.
Does anyone want to brave
forth and try what we might
have as a chorus for this?
Does anyone want to formulate
a line over this beat?
Is anyone brave enough to step
to the mic and try that out?
GARY DUNNE: Are we
happy with this groove?
That's just getting to it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Any objections?
AUDIENCE: Very good.
KARL RYAN: I think we're
getting a asking for forgiveness
rather than permission
kind of vibe.
I like it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
GARY DUNNE: (SINGING)
Light the spark.
Let's light the
spark here people,
come on give me something.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
dark, we have a spark.
GARY DUNNE: Out of the
dark, into the spark.
KARL RYAN: Let's
hear it on the mic.
GARY DUNNE: Sparking all over.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
KARL RYAN: Then look
up into the spark?
I like it.
Do we want to try and
loop it on the mic?
You wanna give it a shot?
AUDIENCE: No.
KARL RYAN: No?
You're just writing the lyric.
You're writing the lyric.
But we need a singer to
bring your vision to life.
All right.
Have we got a
singer in the room?
I see a lot of fingers pointing.
That's cheeky.
GARY DUNNE: (SINGING)
Into the spark.
Out of the dark.
I don't got a part.
Come on.
KARL RYAN: Come on.
Does anyone want
to sing harmony?
I can see fingers pointing.
That's no good.
You can do it.
Give her a big
round of applause.
Come on, come on.
Be brave, be brave.
[APPLAUSE]
Be brave.
You come on.
Yeah, let's do it.
Let's do it.
Come on up.
Sing along with us.
That's what this is about.
It's about having fun.
There's no judgment here.
AUDIENCE: We nominate
ourselves for this chorus.
KARL RYAN: As a
chorus, outstanding.
Are we going on this one, Gary?
GARY DUNNE: Well we--
KARL RYAN: Just so
that we can hear it.
AUDIENCE: Is this on?
So I'm really bad.
She's really good.
I'm just accompanying her.
So if you're really bad like
me, come join the chorus.
[LAUGHTER]
If you think you're--
KARL RYAN: What's
our lyric, here?
GARY DUNNE: Do
you have a melody?
KARL RYAN: Oh,
you have a chorus?
AUDIENCE: (HUMMING)
Like no words at all.
KARL RYAN: Yeah?
GARY DUNNE: It's more ambient?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
GARY DUNNE: Let's do it.
KARL RYAN: All right, let's
[INAUDIBLE] over the beat back.
GARY DUNNE: I'm going to count
you in, so after four-- one,
two, three, four.
AUDIENCE: [SINGING WORDLESSLY]
KARL RYAN: Keep singing it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Got it.
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
It's there.
GARY DUNNE: The spark is--
KARL RYAN: The spark
is still flickering.
But we need more.
We need fire in this room.
So we have a lyric.
And that was a
verse or a chorus?
What do we think?
Was that the chorus?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
KARL RYAN: It was the first.
It was the ver-- So
it was out of the dark
and lighting the spark.
Is that right?
(SINGING) Out of the dark.
GARY DUNNE: (SINGING)
Out of the dark.
It's getting a bit
Beck, now, isn't it,
Karl? (SINGING)
I'm a loser, baby.
So light up my spark.
[LAUGHTER]
KARL RYAN: OK,
we've got a chorus.
But I think somebody
else should sing it.
I'm happy to join in.
Who'd like to sing that?
Let's throw it in the mix.
Can we throw it
in the mix, Gary?
GARY DUNNE: Hoping to take
stock on where we are.
KARL RYAN: OK, let's take stock.
GARY DUNNE: Let's
check out where we are.
We've got a beat.
[BEAT PLAYING]
KARL RYAN: That's my
favorite bit so far.
GARY DUNNE: I think the
beat's fucking amazing, Karl.
KARL RYAN: That's
a really good beat.
GARY DUNNE: Yeah, it's amazing.
It's got a kick and
it's got a snare.
KARL RYAN: It's got
everything you need in a beat.
GARY DUNNE: Then we have a
kind of a bass line thingy.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
And then we have the
choir of no love.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
KARL RYAN: I think we're well
on the way to an amazing theme
song.
GARY DUNNE: I really
like the out of the dark
into the spark thing.
KARL RYAN: Yeah.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
GARY DUNNE: Come on, Karl.
KARL RYAN: Oh, you
want me to sing it?
GARY DUNNE: I don't know.
KARL RYAN: I'll
just vibe it, is it?
GARY DUNNE: Just thinking.
KARL RYAN: (SINGING) Out of
the dark, into the spark.
GARY DUNNE: Yeah.
KARL RYAN: But I liked
what you were going for.
Go for--
GARY DUNNE: (SINGING) Out
of the dark, into the spark.
KARL RYAN: But I
liked the kind of--
GARY DUNNE: Kind of
a blues [INAUDIBLE].
(SINGING) Out of the
dark, into the spark.
KARL RYAN: Yep.
(SINGING) Out of the
dark and into the spark.
GARY DUNNE: Papa got soul.
KARL RYAN: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
It's got coursing through me.
GARY DUNNE: Anybody got
anything as good as Karl has?
KARL RYAN: I see you
getting ready to get up.
Are you ready?
You're with us?
GARY DUNNE: Do it, man.
Do it.
Come on.
Face the fear.
Do it.
[APPLAUSE]
KARL RYAN: All we need
is one line for a verse
and one line for
a chorus, really.
And then we have basically
your average pub song.
[LAUGHTER]
Right?
No?
OK, Lindsey and Boris
are ready to give us
a-- you got something for us?
AUDIENCE: No, we do that--
KARL RYAN: Oh, out of
the spark into the dark?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
KARL RYAN: Out of the
dark, into the spark.
GARY DUNNE: Ready?
Count you in after four.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
GARY DUNNE: And a
one, two, three, four.
AUDIENCE: (SINGING) Out of
the dark, into the spark.
I don't know what the melody is.
[LAUGHTER]
GARY DUNNE: Oh, he does.
KARL RYAN: Doesn't matter,
you just made it up.
AUDIENCE: OK.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
KARL RYAN: You're
not feeling it?
GARY DUNNE: Want to do it again?
KARL RYAN: Go again.
Ready?
GARY DUNNE: I'll
line you up again.
KARL RYAN: Creativity
is hard, sometimes.
[LAUGHTER]
Are we having a good time?
AUDIENCE: Yes!
I'm having a great time.
GARY DUNNE: OK,
we're going again.
I would say something like,
(SINGING) out of the dark,
into the spark.
Out of the dark-- it's
like a soul cross-section.
KARL RYAN: Yeah, I like it.
GARY DUNNE: So, one,
two, three, four.
AUDIENCE: (SINGING) Out of
the dark, into the spark.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
KARL RYAN: All right,
Lindsey and Boris.
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
We're getting there.
GARY DUNNE: It needs a
chicka, chicka, chicka--
KARL RYAN: Oh yeah.
Can somebody give us a chicka,
chicka-- oh, we got some more?
Would you like to come on up?
Whatever you got to
offer, we want to hear it.
Whatever you're putting
down, we're buying.
All right, give a
round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
AUDIENCE: (SINGING) Out of
the dark, into the spark.
GARY DUNNE: Keep doing
it, man, keep doing it.
AUDIENCE: (SINGING) Out of
the dark, into the spark.
Out of the dark, into the spark.
GARY DUNNE: Beautiful.
[APPLAUSE]
[INAUDIBLE]
KARL RYAN:
[IMITATING PERCUSSION]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[INAUDIBLE]
GARY DUNNE: It's cooking.
It's nearly cooked.
KARL RYAN: Nearly cooked.
GARY DUNNE: It's nearly cooked.
It's a little bit--
KARL RYAN: Is there
anybody who can freestyle
hip hop at this point?
[LAUGHTER]
That would be the most
outrageous thing for somebody
to just step up
and go, I got this,
check this out. (RAPPING)
Yo, the spark is
happening when I light
my-- That would be amazing.
Yes?
GARY DUNNE: Do it.
Get on the mic.
KARL RYAN: No?
No?
Yes?
No takers?
No hip hoppers in the room?
No 8-ballers or shot callers?
OK.
That's fine.
GARY DUNNE: I think this is the
moment we go, we wrote a song!
KARL RYAN: We wrote a song!
Ladies and gentlemen,
thank you to Gary Dunne.
And thanks to all of you.
[APPLAUSE]
GARY DUNNE: Thank you very much.
Cheers.
KARL RYAN: So much.
Enjoy the rest of
the refreshments.
And we will be back with
another spark sessions.
We'll be here hanging around.
Thank you to you all.
Thanks to the Cloud Nine team
for putting this together.
And thanks to all of
you for coming out.
This is about community.
It's about creativity.
Go forth and create.
Good night, everybody.
[APPLAUSE]